well welcome welcome to your mom's house
with Christina the shits
to your house it's been a great week we
got a lot of positive feedback on Tom
and I discussing the shower that we took
together there's been multiple showers
before and after now but I was at the
store and red band came up to me and was
like oh what a great episode he goes but
I have to ask you are you serious when
you say that Tom spreads his butt cheeks
and puts it up against the water and I'm
like yeah no that's a real nerve and
then my friend Eric will text me the
same thing like wow that is a bear
marking his territory it sounds like
he's trying to dominate sweet cheeks
yeah pork pork ha which by the way the
people know I'm used to it being your
word I've never heard that right no it's
not a real it's talking a loogie and I
know that so don't fucking email me and
tell me what I'm doing wrong yeah I say
it's working it's just sound that's a
better word for me horking that one
makes me want to vomit and snot on
audience snot rockets it's not right
it's really nice and they were in the
bin your beard and then I peed on your
that's but that's so standard-issue
I thought that was what everybody in any
relationship house well Brian when his
friend whose name I can't remember sorry
but she she was saying that is that true
that he pees on you should I go yeah man
is it that crazy and she's like I've
never been peeing on I'm like won't come
over to my house my head alone pee on
you too lady yeah I feel like that
standard ish in a realize that everybody
does to everyone but actually you're the
first boyfriend that ever peed on me in
the shower huh somehow in dating phone I
wasn't dating savages no you were dating
some non-binary people can I tell you
that before I dated you yeah I was the
man like people thought I was gross like
all my boyfriends would have to tell me
to stop picking my nose you stop farting
and stop burping like my last boyfriend
before you yeah zero tolerance
zero tolerance right towards the end to
really fucking hated it when I wake up
and fall when someone doesn't love you
anymore and you're burping and farting
you think that shit goes over no oh my
god you guys are so disgusting
yeah you're lucky I love you so much
yeah but I but you set the bar so low
for disgusting behavior low hi hi that I
I never have to sort I've trumped you oh
yeah
you think I'm grosser are you really
asking me that question
uh yeah no I know I know I know I know I
totally know it do you know how
disgusting you are not really I just
feel like it's normal you know when we
started dating
you had no soap in your shower I had
shampoo mm-hmm yeah and you use that on
everywhere it's everything you can use
shampoo suds as soap uh-huh
why can you not you can most people
choose not to what am I to go to the
store buy soap - that's the idea
it's fine most people do that's fine
did you when I asked you to buy soap in
your shower where you blown away were
you like this bitch I was just like I
don't understand why you're not using
all the shampoo I got I got all the
shampoo and the best part is to like the
cap was loose on that shampoo bottle so
water would go into it and dilute it so
whatever that may be and last longer yes
you get much better more shampoo more
soap